alors dites-moi est-ce vrai qu'un homme
vous a fait des aveux complet après que
vous l'avez regardé droit dans les yeux
si on a assez de Pat
ience le suspect finit souvent
par s'interroger lui-même
monsieur Hélène d'or
un de nos jeunes cadets
c'est pendu la nuit dernière
c'est l'affaire du médecin légiste je
crains que ça ne s'arrête pas là son
cœur a été extrait de sa poitrine
quel genre d'individu pourrait faire ça
il devrait d'abord être malade mental
j'ai besoin de vous pour déchiffrer cela
d'après la rumeur il y aurait des
instructions pour obtenir l'immortalité
il y a quelqu'un
un autre cadet a disparu bon vous devrez
infiltrer discrètement les cadets
qu'est-ce que c'est du sort du symbole
des rituels oh mon dieu
les hommes font tout ou presque pour
trouver l'amour
quelles sont les faits quels sont les
simples faits la vérité
je pense vraiment que les morts nous
hante parce qu'on les a pas aimé assez
[Musique]
on n'est pas plus proche de trouver qui
est responsable de ces horreurs qui
vient à moi non de dieu
on est tout proche
[Applaudissements]
ce n'est qu'une affaire de temps
[Musique]